10m bees have made it through on to the
ballot you will again have heard us
saying that that's going to take place
on Thursday between 10 a.m. and midday
just let me take you through the names
Michael Gove Matt Hancock Mike Harper
Jeremy Hunt such Javid Boris Johnson
Andrea LEDs some estimate very Dominic
Rob and Rory Stuart's making up those
tents so one didn't make it through he
withdrew just about 45 minutes ago Sun
Jima said he hadn't been able to garner
enough support let's get to instant
reaction from our political editor Beth
Rigby with me now so stayed a long list
then one went but we've got double
figures as I say yes that's why don't we
had thought that there might be two or
three others that might drop out but
they've obviously got enough support to
get through at least to the first round
but really I'd say today all eyes have
been on Jeremy Hunt and Michael Gove
Boris Johnson clearly the front-runner
at the moment Michael Gove had a lot to
do today to try and pull his campaign
back from the brink which I think he
actually did do in that very impressive
actually speech that he gave at his
leadership launch and then of course
Jeremy Hunt knocked the ball out of the
part and he by turning up at his launch
with not one but two cabinet ministers
at brexit here penny mordant and a
remainer in amber art but all eyes now
on Boris Johnson in terms of Dominik
Robb not so good for him because Boris
Johnson is now picking up really the ERG
the Euroskeptic supporting the party
with Jacob Riis morg
Steve Baker over the weekend and now
mark France soir another of the Spartans
as they call themselves coming out for
mr. Johnson but a full list there of ten
candidates I imagine a little drop out
quite quickly in the rounds this week so
quite had quite a few could go after
that first glance about hustings
tomorrow and Wednesday yeah I mean
they're between 10 and 12 on Thursday
yeah that's so it's only the technically
the one on the bottom of the palette
that has to go that things to gathers
may others major I think others may drop
out
if you have a very low number you'll
realize that it might be better at that
point just to move aside and let the
kind of serious six to eight really
battle it out but it's a great platform
for people to put forward their policies
and what you do see in that list of ten
is quite a wide variety of views on
brexit from you know McVeigh who would
even potentially provoke Harlem and as
with Dominic Robert said he would
potentially to try and ensure an exit on
October the 31st you know to the likes
of Rory Stewart who's very much on the
other wing of the partying and and would
want to delay until brexit could be done
Sam dima was the guy he was doing the
second referendum it was considered that
some people might lend their vote to him
just to get him at least into the
discussion around warm but obviously
couldn't get the numbers tonight